how can we identify with someone that in
real life we would never be
you know if you want to say julia
robertson pretty woman well that would
never be something that i would do but
we still root for her we still like her
well if you're a writer i think you have
to realize
identification has nothing to do with
who we are in real life now
it only has to do with emotion it only
has to do with
empathy because we there's
nothing in real life that would make me
like
sully or whatever his name is an avatar
i'm nothing like indiana jones i'm
nothing like
the hero of shrek but that isn't what
that's not why we go to movies we don't
really go to movies to
become characters that are so much like
we are we can see those people by going
home
that's those are the people we want to
get away from what you want to do is
create that empathy using those tools so
we become them
on an emotional psychological level
that's the fun of it so we become
a space traveler 200 years in the future
we become a soldier of fortune we become
an ogre
whatever we become a woman uh
on the titanic so those two things are
really
better thought of as disconnected
completely i think
yeah also also along that line i agree
totally with what michael's saying but
that we can we connect with characters
on an emotional level
and if you take any of the characters
that you've mentioned and michael's
mentioned and you say okay
that person's life is nothing like mine
i am
not shrek i am not indiana jones i'm
nothing but
my life is so much like him because i
suffer
and experience all the emotions that he
goes through
i i have feelings of abandonment i have
feelings of
of pride i have a feelings of
discouragement in other words
i can identify with him emotionally not
that i want to be
him or be like him but i like to know
that he is
actually not that different from me in
other words there is a similarity but
the similarity is on the emotional
experiential level
not on the action level or the career
level
if you take like you mentioned titanic
there you have the two lovers on titanic
do we all understand falling in love yes
hopefully we all do do we all understand
being in danger yes do we do do we all
understand
fears of death and dying yes we do
dessert have we ever been on the titanic
no or sinking boat no i mean in other
words we haven't been there but
what we can the experience is that these
a good film will allow us to have
with the characters with with this not
identifying with the character
except on the emotional level and that's
where we get hooked
and that that's how we we um
not only empathize that we project
ourselves in into them and we
play them when you read a script you
play all the characters even when you
watch a film you actually
project yourself inside the character to
go on
not the um adventure of indiana jones
but the experience the emotional
experience that ride that's the ride you
want to go on
and that and that's what makes us
connect potentially with this film on a
very very deep level
it used to be when i when i used to work
for production companies and it seemed
like
every year or two i'd get this people
would come in and pitch ideas
and there was always someone who'd come
in and have a pitch like
this movie the script i write it's going
to be huge
because it's about a bowler and then
they'd say do you know that
30 million people in this country bowl
and i my answer was always well first of
all if they're bowling they're not going
to the movies so we're not going to get
any money out of them
but that's not why people go to the
movies to see people who are doing what
they already do
it has to do with just what mark said
it's it's not situational it's emotional
it's are they feeling what i have felt
at least to some extent maybe not as big
as they do but if i
experienced this before on the inside
that's what creates the connection
you